hey what's happening country cousin
bigquery third co representative missy
the native chick me out on the bullet
kill podcast
boulet kev show special guest in here
one of the greatest rappers of all time
we've had a good day of rappers crooked
i was here this morning oh word okay
look at it
crooked eye is one of them guys
definitely definitely welcome man big
crit what's good bro uh you were telling
me we just left this girl talk you uh
we're gonna get to your album but you
whiz smoke dizzy girl talk yeah
this album kind of came out of nowhere
i'm not even gonna lie yeah definitely
did that i mean but we we worked on it
in 2019 it's and it's just crazy the
timing of music it just makes a lot of
sense right now too i mean everybody's
back outside these are my brothers and
we've been rocking each other for years
from the jump yeah and that [ __ ] was
just so organic bro like it was we
literally one day in the studio girl
talk had all the craziness beats to the
point where once we did it girl talk did
all the mixing you know arranged
everything sequence and i literally just
heard the album last week that's crazy
and i was like and i trust the homie
because i know he's very meticulous with
music and so i'm hearing the breakdown
of the song i got on there and i'm like
damn you chop the [ __ ] out of that beat
and i'm listening to it for the like oh
[ __ ] i didn't dish it you got a
different appreciation too as a producer
yeah yeah
you guys uh dizza whiz and yourself i
feel like all kind of
will be kind of somewhat tied together
yeah forever yeah just based on and
currency obviously but just based on the
smoker's club on
obviously the the records early on and
um cushion on cushion orange juice and
glass house and all that like
i feel like this is a kind of a
nostalgic project for for guys like
myself who missed that era of hip-hop
what we like to call maybe the early
blog era yes yeah early blog era
um
what like i guess for you
what was your thought process and saying
like
yeah this is this feels right because
you know whis has got a lot going on you
got a lot going on this is doing a whole
lot of [ __ ] he's doing weed he's doing
podcasts albums everything um
i heard that you guys did this in one
day yeah one session yeah i mean
everybody else had solo records with
girl talk before that i'm sure and that
gave us the opportunity to have our own
like individual songs but i think man it
was for me it was a breath of fresh air
it was the kind of album where not only
did we not expect to do it and we just
[ __ ] got into like oh this [ __ ] is
going to come out crazy but
not having the pressure of it thinking
about it like it's
a label album kind of thing or all you
got to be very calculated we was like
[ __ ] it we making jam and ass music
and then put it together and it's out
now you know um and for me i i needed
this opportunity with the homies too
because it just reminds me of why i even
do it and when i started and the feel of
that um and we as being the first person
i even went on tour with you know back
in 2010 so i was like man we it's a
different kind of you know family
friendship especially in this music
industry that bro we we came together
mates with jam [ __ ] lily just had fun
bro which tour was the 2010 tour
christian orange juice that was the the
original cushion orange juice yeah bro i
literally yeah we was out there like
you know
like like when you when you hear a
record like last house and like kind of
like when we think back to like maybe
how important that record was and how it
kind of just helped
um it really kind of i think it helped
everyone out and it's such a cultural
like
i think of one train right that's
another one of those definitely i think
glass house is like one of those as well
it just kind of encapsulated
that time period and south by southwest
south by south west
free mixtapes [ __ ] it man do every show
you can standing on you know not even on
a stage just freestyling and [ __ ] in the
street yeah how often do you go back and
then listen to that record and like what
memories does that record give you bring
a lot of memories people people want you
know me to perform that song i don't
you're the best you had the best verse
on that right i mean i mean thank you
you know i appreciate that but um for me
it was just like i think wiz and
currency know that respectfully they
know you i mean look yeah let's be
honest i will say the way that record
came about and then what happened with
my career after was because the homies
was definitely
not only crushing it but christian
orange juice was
i mean i think it was about to come out
and just the excitement behind everybody
and kind of being new artists and we
were getting our own separate deals and
uh doing that record put me put my name
in front of a lot of people that wasn't
aware of what i was doing
because was glass house before crit was
here yeah i think glass house we did
that 2010 march then cruiser came out in
april or may yeah i was about to say it
felt like it was like a like right
before yeah and so that that put me in a
lot of people cars and you're like who
is this [ __ ] and then between
the beat because even the kind of track
i don't the homies would initially
always rap on that kind of kind of thing
too
um and so after that going on tour being
able to perform that with wiz and
currency just kind of kept putting my
name out there up until we did the 2011
double xl cover that's when people
really saw who i was because i wouldn't
even put my face on covers and [ __ ] my
father doesn't know what the [ __ ] i look
like that's real you were kind of you
were low-key early on yeah you know and
so your face wasn't on any of the
artwork nah very very just the brand
crit name and uh i remember going out on
the road with wiz and then black and
yellow had took off while he was on the
road and just i was living in vegas that
[ __ ] was so crazy bro yeah and the
energy and i know it was it was
thousands of people had no idea who the
[ __ ] i was but it definitely gave me
opportunity a platform to get new fans
yeah that was a that was a moment black
and yellow was one of them records where
it was like
oh whiz got one now like okay the suit
oh the 1-1 the ones here
cause before that i was like okay he's
up next but yeah but once you catch one
of them that [ __ ] took off bro yeah if
it puts you in a different uh sphere for
sure
um
i what i also appreciate is i actually
recently got to purchase crit was here
on vinyl hey well then thank you i was
at amoeba and i was surprised to see it
hmm yeah and i was like wait a minute
[ __ ] i don't know if this is bootleg or
not i hope not
but no i mean it was just amazing to be
able to have it out on streaming
platforms for people to listen to it now
i was gonna say like i know that was an
uphill battle
um yeah i mean because you wanna it's
not only sample clearances i mean and me
is also the thought process behind not
wanting it to sound
not wanting to lose clean it up too much
wanting people to still get that same
feel some wreckers didn't make it you
know some things had to change but it's
still a blessing man all these years to
be able to put that out and people
actually wanted to listen i'm just happy
that
i don't have to go to that piff anymore
yeah uh yeah on youtube and it cut off
after youtube is the worst yeah so you
know but now we out here man and it's
just to have a catalog is a beautiful
thing too bro a hundred percent and you
have a catalog yeah i was like over 400
[ __ ] songs you have 400 songs on
dsp's got to got to be at this point
that makes sense yeah so how many albums
officially now that 10 10 albums wow
yeah i think uh you know meena would say
10 yeah so in in in
still having the
hunger to do this that's not even
including the little eps you dropped
like four years ago
freestyle shits and all that all the
features combined definitely got a lot
of music out here oh with features
combined you're over 400 oh yeah while
now
yeah you know snapping though there's a
song i recently uh that just came up on
my youtube uh i don't know i was just
listening to music and it was the
fullest [ __ ] records you did with oh
yeah that's it yellow yeah
that that record is disrespectful yo
rich's verse on that song is so
i'm like bro if you dropped this in 2022
you getting cancelled yeah but that [ __ ]
was jamming for what the time period but
now we can't yeah yeah they got that
[ __ ] got to stay back there the hook
alone is just yeah yes i guess i'm fully
yeah that's real um
let's talk about digital roses don't die
sir
love the title thank you i think it fits
the vibe of this project
you've dabbled with some funky [ __ ] in
the past but i feel like with this album
you fully committed to just a different
vibe than when we get in the car and
press play on a qriket album yeah
where's your head where's your head at
when you're making this project and it
sounds amazing i think you executed it
amazingly thank you i mean for me i just
didn't want to
drop an album coming out of 2020 and
2021 that sounded like what people know
me for i wanted to
change and show the kind of growth not
only i've gotten mentally but musically
and grounded and comfortable like i it's
okay for me to make a funky record of
singing on my entire eye you sound great
singing man hey man i did my best you
sound good
not too much yeah but yeah [ __ ] who
isn't using tunes let's be honest but
those [ __ ] are using tunes on
their rapping versus but the thing was
too bro it's like you can't there's
nobody to feature for you in your life
right yeah so when writing this album
it's like if it's a love album the only
two voices that you hear constantly is
me and um this amazing singer named
roland right it's this back and forth
for me and this woman kind of
relationship thing and so records like
generational way down it's my story is
how i feel so despite how many notes i
might hit this bad i have to sing this
because it's how it's i wrote it and
it's
it's my personal experience and so
starting to think about music like that
kind of changed how i even approach an
album at this point right
and it's amazing that the girl talk
album is coming out because i get to be
young spirited you know maybe people
that missed that glass house country
[ __ ] but myself and that's cool but
dallas was in my 20s you know i'm in my
30s and i'm supposed to grow and your
fans are growing man yeah i mean [ __ ]
they got kids most of them facts you
know what i'm saying or they then went
through the college experience and
they're trying to get their house you
know how many i mean if you're thinking
2010 was doing i mean that's 12 years
yeah and i was but i started my first
project came out in 2004.
that's crazy you know what i'm saying
and so i've been i've i've done that and
i've been in 18 years yeah bro
yeah the first beat i ever made was in
1999. so
2001 i dropped my first mixtape in my
city it literally was uh 21 years ago
yeah wow yeah so it's like i've been
doing it so to be able to be as
vulnerable as i was on this album to
make a record like more than roses and
have that flute the the dude killed it
that was the closest thing i've ever got
to making something willie hutch would
make something that i just cracked that
way you know and and to me that's that's
that's what i do this for bro i got to
challenge myself it's very it it just
gave me like a really like timeless
feel yeah like this [ __ ] will live in
like 10 years it could have lived in
1978 it could have been exactly and if
you go with if you in a relationship
it's something in this album that's for
you yeah you might be you might not be
with it now but you don't worry
you're going you'll go you're there
you're going to go through one of these
[ __ ] tracks you know now i love
the title too just like because we live
in a world in which everything is
digital and you know
what what was your motivation to that
digital roses don't die well there was
two different perspectives the first one
was the fact that we document our
relationships in a sense and even if
you're not with that person that stuff
is still out there to see still on the
internet they could bring you down or it
can encourage you depending on how you
feel yeah i didn't think that but in the
grander scheme we've been digital way
longer than what we think my dad showed
me a picture of my uh sent me a picture
of my grandparents when they were super
young together and then i'm looking at
this and i'm like this is a digital rose
you know neither one of my grandparents
are here but this has been passed down
from generation to generation and i'm
gonna get to pass it down to my kids as
well so this is way bigger than it just
being the internet this is your own
personal experience and journey
being documented and people get to look
back at it and it goes from not only the
people in the picture but who took the
photo what was happening during that
time period you know we seen pictures of
people that dealt with the spanish flu
and mask everybody no we just saw that
yeah now we we we got photos like that
we got we got documented time we gonna
be like yeah we're living we're living
in history right now we don't even
realize it because we're in it like man
what the [ __ ] were they wearing man 15
years from now we're going to look back
and be like y'all remember it's crazy
them two years were crazy and so and for
me it's just about expressing that and
wanting people to really take heed and
document and give those roses today to
each other now it's very important
i'm glad you did this collab project
because we've always been teased with
you doing collab projects with artists
and they've never happened you and
yellow over
but that would have been like yeah and
he's a he's a monster that would have
been instead of like spy versus spy
he's a monster so it's and but these
this this this kind of gave me the
confidence moving forward to like i
listen let's collab more because this is
if and for me it's i have to let go of
the reigns a little bit too not wanting
to produce i gotta say because you
handle so much of the creative process
for all of your music
i fell back this time i mean it was a
collective effort of being in the studio
so we trust each other's hook writing
capabilities we know who verse would
sound better first or second you know
i'm saying oh i don't even need to be on
that song that's all you bro cause you
snapping and then having that kind of
confidence in your skill that's what
makes the album jamming because we know
we all gonna snap is you know what i'm
saying so that's real yeah if you uh
you're one of the you know there's some
great producer slash artists obviously
kanye j cole don't get enough love for
this no you don't j cole
was a
he don't produce as much as he used to i
mean when he first came into the game he
gets taxing too though bro when you sit
in there having to make the beat right
the hook you know do the verse it's a
challenge i feel like uh what was it uh
the last was it the last album was the
first time you kind of totally were like
prettiest here i was like yeah you were
like one record that was blue flame
ballet which was fire see but i was
still i was letting people know that was
a great [ __ ] record like that i'm
gonna go this way you know but
um and that but even working with them
showed me that is other ways of me
trying to work on music that i don't
have to stick with samples
anymore or even the idea of it so if
you're listening to uh digital roses
don't die there's no samples i was going
to say like producing um an album like
this where there's live instrumentation
you talked about bringing in a food
player yeah that's got to add a
different element to just your whole
process that's got to be kind of fun oh
it was fun but it is it's it also makes
it a little bit more difficult right how
about saving scary because you [ __ ] off
and go so
like it's like that thousand digit rules
things like oh i'm gonna put this in and
put this in it spend months on a record
a little bit more expensive too and play
it for people and they don't get what
the [ __ ] you where you going with it
it's like i'm gonna take this risk yeah
and that's in that and i took it i
really took that risk because i remember
even when i did the record show you
write they went through so many versions
of that song before when i would play it
people would get it but in the beginning
it was like they still don't get it i
gotta highlight the homie mo dre so he
can do the talk box so i can the funk so
you can actually feel where i'm going
and these elements can change the
listener's ear quickly
yeah um
it was definitely a risk but i think
there's a few people who could pull pull
that [ __ ] off i'm not sure you're
capable of doing anything really
terrible i mean
if i did you would never hear it yes
because i know i know i know i'd have
made some [ __ ] but you'll never hear you
know what i'm saying but that's about
that's a part of the creative process
like it normally starts in the morning i
give me some good piano chords going and
i go to sing it then by that time i'm
shooting the idea over the dutch like
bro what you think about this and then
through the
only just playing it through the speaker
and like that's hard and then i just
keep building from there um talk to me
about your def jam era because as a fan
it was extremely frustrating yeah um
because i had always
i guess when you ended up at def jam i
was like oh now this full it's always
going down right and we have the hill
pop
what def jam finally he's got the
machine behind because before that you
were just cinematic yeah okay at the
time um
and i just felt like
in at least from a fan's perspective
they grossly mishandled you or just does
not did not know what to do with big
crit well the the the the building that
signed me
like i think two weeks a month later was
gone that happens a lot and then so you
you you're already kind of starting off
rocky because you're not working with
the people that may have been people who
believed
man i was determined and shout out to
shot money in my team i was determined
to produce my first album no matter what
i was like man it was a goal and it was
something that i needed to do for myself
because it was that idea old crit sign
why should [ __ ] change up so i just like
[ __ ] that you know and then i went
right into doing all the beats and
wanting to keep it the same way i did
with the mixtapes uh and with the
projects at the time and so what
happened is the samples of some samples
i couldn't clear some features i
couldn't get then when you're mixing
that kind of stuff and you're having to
remove things off the whim it just
changed the narrative of what the album
originally would have felt like because
i i couldn't get sample clearances and
we fought for a lot of the records and i
had the i learned to change them she's
like three days before i had to turn
album in kind of stuff and i've been
listening to this live and underground
song a certain kind of way and then it
comes down to the whole other way i got
them i got to change it i got to get
this piano played but try to make it
sound old but you know what it's like
when you sample something then you try
to recreate it sometimes it's not quite
right but
in that album we show people that just
because you're not getting the label
support and they don't know what to do
it doesn't mean that people aren't going
to buy it it was a great album yeah and
me and my and my supporters came through
and then first week sales [ __ ]
looking at us like how did y'all do that
i was like i mean y'all like i have they
my people they come out you know but
even with singles trying to get the
single push and then [ __ ] we dropped
money on the floor in 2011
september my album didn't come out till
june 2012.
so i had to literally trying to promote
him single
for them near a year okay so [ __ ] was
here came out
when did return to forever drop 2011. it
came out march and then was the third
tape before the album forever forever in
a day i dropped think about that i had
in order to keep the momentum going i
knew how cause forever in a day you
would already wear on death jam right
yeah i had to drop something in order to
keep the
while they went on this out you're like
i mean
between you and wiz and i'm probably
forgetting but you guys had the albums
that weren't albums but they were albums
yeah i mean but that was the best way to
keep people engaged it was free you know
because they weren't mixtapes they were
like this new thing where people were
just giving away real albums
that was the best that was your best
calling card at the time though yeah
like and then if you and then for me it
was like man i want to make sure that
this project competes with these major
label albums regardless of how i'm doing
it in my room we drop it randomly and
that's what it did to the point people
was like forever today should have been
your album
you know and i had to i had to i had to
check that with a grain of salt but i'm
like i spent a different kind of energy
it was different you didn't have to
worry about nobody even knows all the
red tape i just popped up and was like
yo
i remember forever in a day
did drop out of nowhere yeah because i
told you i said we need to do something
it's like remember right
there's a there's a print tape on two
dope boys
bro we need to drop this and then it
becomes this thing where i had so much
creative
freedom to do it yeah so it i'm [ __ ]
working the cover the everything about
it just became oh that could have been
my album
what is your my favorite project of
yours is returner forever what is you if
you if you had to if you had to like
tell one like i don't know let's say
[ __ ] aliens came down and they're
like yeah what's your best album we're
trying to take the [ __ ] to mars what's
the album you you give them i got i
gotta say it's it's for it's forever's a
mighty long time in return forever i
think those two pretty much sum up
the growth and what i'm capable of and
that was about a long time was uh not
only a process but it was this beautiful
way of me telling people that i have
these
dual ways of thinking about my career
and then wanting to be this turned
artist and i love you know performing
that but i got so much more to say
and here and then sometimes i don't even
know if music
if i'm getting my point across with the
event enough or if drinking sessions is
like
i'm doing this stuff because i feel this
way and it's not just me trying to shock
value kind of thing and so just being
able to be that open that creative and i
appreciate my team for letting me do a
double album which nobody was doing it
at the time that's true like that's a
lot of music one was like bro that's a
lot and then it's not even split up on
itunes it's just one
well that's the thing about nowadays
it's like if you drop a double album you
just drop a long ass playlist
ass playlist if it's not broken up in
pieces but in fact
even doing the justin scott intro is
like i sampled my own intro to create
the big crit intro
so this is just small things it's like
man i'm i'm always taking the next step
creatively if i can hey we got to stop
the interview real quick man shout out
to our sponsors at my bookie now if
you're into sports like me you like to
win money
what are we doing go to my bookie right
now man let's get in on some of this
action
my bookie go sign up get the double
deposit bonus that's what this means
when you sign up in my bookie right now
all right whatever money you would
deposit they're gonna match it they're
gonna double it for you up to a thousand
dollars but you gotta use the keyword
the promo code
bootleg that's right use that promo code
bootleg when you sign up at mybookie
they're gonna double your deposit listen
march madness is coming up
my favorite time of the year to gamble
is march madness it is so much fun you
don't got to know a [ __ ] thing about
college basketball it is just [ __ ]
turnt up
i love to go to
listen march madness that's really all
you need to know get your account before
then thank me later also nba action is
finally back throw down some futures who
do you think is going to win the mvp
joel embiid jokic devin booker a little
dark horse you know i'm saying shout out
to the suns uh you got to go to my
bookie though sign up get down right now
all right get double your money double
your deposit you put in a thousand
they're going to match that give you a
whole another thousand to gamble with
mybooky.ag
use the promo code bootleg double your
deposit
your favorite posse cut you've been a
part of
posse could
because let's go through them man i mean
you're part of some of the best ever i'm
looking at joey badass picture right now
i'm like that uh the record we did with
echo underground airplanes
i remember that
i missed when clothing brands used to do
songs
like a [ __ ] lrg mixtape echo yeah
that's it was hard but it's between that
and one train i got off on one track one
train is like i went the [ __ ] off
it's like it should be in a museum to me
i'm gonna tell you just being a funny
story about this [ __ ] the reason why i
was like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna
do a i'm gonna do a 32. i'ma just keep
going we do the uh bt award cipher
bt tell us write 12 bars to this
instrumental mm-hmm cool we get to the
site for everybody kicking [ __ ] 48s
and 64's and [ __ ] my versus a 12. i'm
like i'll never again get a
[ __ ] instrumental and not just
go crazy so once rocky sent me to me and
i love the way he did it because it was
like nobody heard nobody's verse so
he'll go to instrumental bro any idea
who was going to be i don't know who the
[ __ ] was going to be on the song
yeah i'm like i
i'm so young
wow i'm gonna go [ __ ] crazy and the
bb king line r.i.p the legend cause who
it was yourself wolf joey badass
uh danny brown yeah uh
[Music]
kendrick was on it kendrick was on it
yeah [ __ ] that was it that was a moment
that's crazy that was the moment yeah
it's it's so easy that was bold for that
one that was that was dope well i just
think that like
you said that you you you view your
career through two different
perspectives at times or at least on
that on that album you you said that you
had kind of communicated that mm-hmm
for every day i do the same thing i feel
like
when it like like
a lot of people
have you in the guards of like being one
of the greatest right of all time of
your generation whatever i actually put
out a a
do you i don't you remember when that
hundred rappers someone put out a uh i
saw the list yeah but i put out i put
out a list and i think i had you like in
the top 20 or 25 years ago and i had
people in the car i had freddy super
high i had you super high
pusha t was
super hot i had you above a little wayne
for sure yeah okay okay okay people
didn't like that i'm pretty sure they
didn't but um
you know in one regard you're like in
that conversation amongst
the people who know
and then on the other side of the coin
it's like i still feel like somehow you
haven't met your potential commercially
yet yeah and i'm not saying that that
day is not coming yeah i mean it's it's
most people would say traditionally i
haven't had a quote-unquote hit country
[ __ ] probably was the biggest closest
thing that was the biggest record and i
think from that it was uh
i tried to play the sweetie and little
wayne song at real in l.a i was fighting
to get that [ __ ] on the mick show thank
you so thank you and now and even that
record sometimes i've just been ahead of
the curve just a little yeah cause that
was a little pre before sweetie really
caught her you know
and then even with having a record with
future right
just last week the record with two
children i forgot about that so yeah man
so it's for me it's always wanting to
work with people and just because i'm
[ __ ] what they sound and then
obviously things take off but
um it's just been the narrative but i
never chased it i never was like i think
pay attention when working with rico
love also was the closest thing that was
yeah because that was starting to get
some yeah and then that was me trying to
find and kind of grow up a little more
than what people was used to it was it
was that was a different record for you
this is the wooden chain and you know
the the oh i forgot about the wooden
chain that was kind of
it's like i'm growing up you know um but
going through all those things really
showed me that people
i don't have a box that i'm in so people
if it's jamming they cool with what i
present
um and then just now doing it in the
most
authentic way as i possibly can you know
but those are great periods i go back
and look at them videos i'm like man we
the quality for what it for the times
for not necessarily having the certain
kind of label support that most would be
i never slacked on the fact that i
wanted to give people the best of me
right and i remember what live from the
underground kind of went through with
the critique of it um how people felt
about it coming back doing catalactica
then people going back and being like
you know what laughing underground was
jamie i liked cadillac but like i i mean
listen i like that one too yeah i mean i
mean but it was just it was always like
and keep in mind bro be telling people
that man i had to create a whole planet
i created a whole planet rapt about it
the story of it and it was still like
y'all still don't see like i'm do you
want to know what it is i think
that when you come out with with two
projects like crit was here
and return it forever it's kind of like
when nas came out with illmatic and it
was written
do you remember like nas could do no
right if it wasn't do you remember how
long it's like here
i just feel like you have some of the
greatest bodies of work that we've heard
in the last 20 years and so when you
have those bodies of work even if the
other [ __ ] is fire
people are always going to be like but
with the vent yeah i mean and and once
you're at peace with it that's just what
it is which you obviously are just just
keep put just keep doing you and running
it up it is crazy though i remember once
crippled came out and just what happened
next and then returning forever 2011 and
just the movement behind the that album
and so for me it's like i get it this is
it still was like first introductions
too though this was like oh man it was
new for what it was at the time i'm from
mississippi and so to be that country
and free and then it was just you know
it was people first introduction with me
yeah 2010 i think you won uh dj's
djbooth.net uh album or mixtape of the
year double xl yeah i remember that year
specifically because it was you it was
crit was here it was trunk music
and it was
i'm thinking of i'm trying to think
about we've been doing this for a minute
but just what a great [ __ ] like can
you do you remember how great it was to
just be like
just for no red tape let's just drop
music i just as a fan it's my favorite
era ever because there was just so much
[ __ ] and it was so easy to put people on
the music and they was there and it was
waiting everything was i don't know but
it you know it was pre-streaming still
right so there was this aspect
people [ __ ] with your music they had to
go get it they had to seek it out they
had to download it they had the receipt
they had to get a virus on their lap on
her computer
these eggs for sure some of those drinks
yeah
pop up crazy [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ]
that's funny man but yeah i um
i've been blessed to be able to see both
now it's a transition you know trying to
see how the music game works in this era
and how this feels because content is
king right um but for me it's just once
again never losing the fact that i love
when people listen to my music in their
car when they go from point a to point b
and what that means to them so i'm never
gonna just for the sake of what's
happening in the music energy short
people on what i bring to the table
um
this so this girl talk project would be
your second project in about a month and
some change
i hear you may or may not already have
something coming soon
don't worry about that okay
but yeah i mean come on i mean you've
been resting for a couple of years right
i'm assuming you've been working a lot i
got a lot of [ __ ] bro and then this is
this this is the step in the right
direction of me staying more
out in the front doing more music
because people know me to do album and
then probably disappear for a year or
two so now i was like nah i'm gonna
constantly drop this time
and um i'm excited because then you know
it's it's that they still get that turn
element of me the growth of me too and
um branding multi is very important
because i got my label and now it's like
really trying to put artists out that i
that i i deem that i want people to
really hear who are some of those
artists now i mean we'll roll in the the
young lady that's singing on the album
her voice is amazing okay you know what
i'm saying and at this moment i think
just focusing and wanting to work with
her um and there's a couple artists man
but i don't wanna you know i ain't
played ain't put it together yet for
real who was that dope ass singer from
atlanta um that used to be on everyone's
[ __ ]
sometimes she wouldn't even get featured
uh nakia was that her name sounds
familiar does that sound right dutch
nakia she was hard i just think
she was like on help she was on hell of
[ __ ] that's random random tidbit let's
talk about team because i do feel like
teen is so important in the music
industry and i want to just give some
love to your guy dutch because research
has been your running mate for a very
long time yeah man that's the the growth
though cause dutch started off as uh my
tour manager
so being out there on the road and
actually kind of putting up with how i
was as an artist and then being able to
be very influential with being in the
studio being around for those times and
then getting to the point where like yo
bro manage me right and then to see what
and it's great too because dutch is his
own entity now right yeah yeah you know
what i'm saying it's like he is his own
own thing and so it's just dope to see
the growth in me and him both not only
me as an artist but him as a businessman
has it been like um
you know are you kind of like coming
from two different eras of music into
the streaming era
what are the things that you've kind of
had to like
maybe
pinch your nose because you know i think
a tick tock tick tock is one of those
things
that we think of it's like man it's some
kitty ass [ __ ] but i'm just starting to
notice like even the artist you would
never think would be on tick tock it's
kind of like you have to be on tick tock
i mean it comes with the territory of
what we do it's kind of like the new
sound cloud yeah yes and it's very quick
how a record can take off on that right
it's become a radio station within
itself
and um so you kind of got to move it
where the music is going right and then
to be gone for two years
you i can't be mad at people to pick up
another form of learning and finding out
about artists and it's it's going and i
remember even ig being something i was
like all right you take a picture of
your food oh this is what i'm wearing
today you know what i'm saying like but
steals this is like man you can just be
in your bed
just talking to you you know what i'm
saying
totally remove smoking mirrors it's
crazy
it's the most transparent
uh well fans and artists relationship
or dynamic is the most transparent it's
ever been which is why
i feel like it's it's a lot harder to
fake the [ __ ] now you could buy you know
streams i think the live show will pull
the curtain back on whether or not you
got real quick
but in terms of just like
i think about r b
do you remember like us growing up every
r b singer was a beautiful man with a
six pack and chiseled and had the
perfect hair and now it's post malone in
the weekend i mean look you know what
i'm saying
it's it's and and but the music is so
good and and i think people are like yo
i i see through the
the product yeah yeah cause you know
those guys were products i mean but
anything
the understanding that people want to
see and listen to people that look like
this they can relate to they want to
feel like they're yeah yeah i mean
because we definitely run into the
understanding that that particular
individual or however they present
themselves might not be realistic to how
you can present yourself yeah like cisco
with a leather jack abrax jacket opened
up with a 12-pack and bleached hair
dancing in the rain i'm gonna be and i
loved cisco's solo album expected but i
don't think i wanted to dye my hair
silver ever at all so a lot of guys did
they did my older brother did can you
imagine do you remember we because of
cisco we all used to wear fitted hats
with chinese letters on them ah i had no
idea what they said you would have the
fitted hat and yeah the chinese letter
and then on the back it'd be the
baseball team or the curly well you
probably do this but the sideburns that
was kind of like yeah yeah
the genuine type burns yeah they yeah it
wasn't yeah i didn't do those though i
didn't do those i feel like i feel like
yeah i do feel like that's kind of the
positive thing that social media has
done is it's kind of like even the
playing field in a sense where like you
don't have to be like
you almost would rather be more
relatable and like
i want to have a beer with you and not
[ __ ] you
you know what i'm saying um not me
specifically
what the [ __ ] yeah i feel what you're
saying though i mean but it's again it's
it's pulling the curtain back i think
it's allowing artists not only to be
more transparent but it's still it's
getting to that it's getting to being
able to show that all right i have
anxiety oh this frustrates me oh i don't
like what's going on in my in my deal or
my career um so it's definitely giving
people more that platform to not be so
scared to actually express their
discomfort a lot of that's been
happening um and they go and this is
right there meek mill nba young boy
i mean everyone has been
being someone who's kind of experienced
all sides of the game
if there's an up and coming artist who's
watching this who might have a little
something going on and labels always
trying to sign you
there's majors there's many majors
there's you know it's just yeah
distribution whatever right
would you suggest someone go the major
label route right now i mean well this
depends on what they want in the
beginning right i as an artist i wanted
to be played on the radio i wanted to be
assigned to a major because it's just
this grandiose thing about doing music
if they feel that the deal is structured
in a way that they can still get the joy
of being signed and it be fair then by
all means do it my personal experience
might not be like someone else's i know
a lot of artists at our side and they
seem to get a fair shake in it they get
the check they get the support they do
the late night shows and it seems to
work it didn't necessarily work for me
right and so i can't expect somebody to
take my
role with it because this isn't easy you
know it's definitely a role less
traveled you it's like being it's like
being on a private airport i talk about
all this time it's like when you were
the label it's a huge airport and it's
planes leaving you're at lax you know
going independent you're at burbank you
get to walk right through yeah but
when it's when when the air is full you
can't take off this is true and
it's harder to get to some destinations
there's connecting flights you gotta you
gotta connect yeah so and for me it's
like once we figured it out but it was
so weird once we left def jam and we
told people that i was leaving it was so
many [ __ ] they're like well you
you signing them yeah i don't think a
lot of people knew that who weren't
supposed to say i was wrong tied to the
song like he was like yeah i was with
them
for six seven years
it was a minute and as it's like oh we
didn't even [ __ ] know it's like it's
so crazy it's it's crazy too because
like i think of like
i just don't know i don't know man as a
fan i just was like what the [ __ ] is def
jam doing like none like anything you'd
like feature wise or like all that [ __ ]
it was we there was some still some
great people we we met there and then
even with me it was the understanding
that i'm from the south i'm from a place
that a lot of people haven't even been
right so when you talk about trying to
create a certain kind of um what's the
word i want to use support in a building
where they seeing their favorite artists
come through all the time right and it
was a lot of young people and yeah they
might [ __ ] with me as a person but they
weren't might not been into my music
might not have knew about my music they
want to promote for their favorite
artists right
and so you know you run into that and
then you get the the situation where you
the album come out you go in the office
and everybody in the building playing
your songs and you like i know good and
damn well y'all don't do this every day
and so when you appreciate them trying
yeah but we went out and we was we knew
that i had um hard ticket sales that i
had support from people because i was on
the ground and we was doing all the runs
meeting the djs and i'm very hands-on
with how i interact with people and so
that helped my career tremendously bro
that it didn't matter that we didn't
have certain
outlets and certain press and push
because we still were selling our shows
correct me if i'm wrong because i don't
remember if you were on these albums
because it i was we were talking about
this album earlier
did russ tap in with you on any of the
chomps
yeah i'm going to i'm going to chop down
trump too
okay okay make sure i'm not tripping
yeah okay okay okay shout out to the
homie for that because he get busy too
yeah i mean he pretty much just grabbed
like every rapper that was like
incredible in the world that would work
with him i [ __ ] with the fact that he it
was a toe-to-toe thing it's like and
he's sending you his verse too and that
take a lot just be like all right this
is what i did and i'm totally
comfortable with you hearing what i did
a lot of people don't do that nah
because they want to be able to be like
uh i got out i got to go back in nah he
was very confident with like hey i did
what i did here
yeah
shout out to russ yeah man he's uh
he's doing his thing [ __ ] independently
are you are you staying independent are
you yeah man
uh um a label can only partner with my
label i'll never physically sign to a
major smart move man it's like i'm past
that point i wouldn't even begin to know
how to play that game how do you pick
like because
i mean do you do you link up with the
distribute a distributing partner or do
you do straight tune core no bmg bmg is
distributed yeah that's dope man it's
one of them situations where
i work on the music me and my team feel
comfortable with it and then we drop the
album it's not like i go in and have to
play it and get nothing like well we
passed it ain't no ain't no performing
on tables and [ __ ]
did you ever have never did i was about
to say did you ever have to know
you would have broke the [ __ ] table
i'm just letting you know
yeah but i wasn't going through that
how like your live show has always been
one of the more special ones in hip-hop
because i feel like if you're on stage
and it's just you and the dj and no
[ __ ] going on
you're killing it you're gonna turn up i
mean i i learned from uh banner david
banner
david banner david batter and then
yellow wolf was would go crazy yellow
wolf was special i mean he still is
special yeah i'm going crazy on stage
and so it was one of those things even
when he was like oh like south by
southwest that was climbing up on [ __ ]
just jumping off those early south by
shows where like uh yeah legends things
the legends are made of a house bro we
was wild and magma all of us she's
crazy on stage bro that's those were the
days where you could actually like like
you could go to south by and leave with
a deal yeah because that's what you
that's why i'm a wolf yeah yeah i mean
[ __ ] the wolf who else i think i think
stanley got kendrick i think you have a
currency everybody we went down there
and then yeah
yeah i don't know what it is now i'm
gonna go next week unfortunately i'm
gonna go but oh well yeah i don't damn
it is next week i haven't been in a long
time don't go i'm going
i'm going because i have to go but you
know what those days are like oh yeah 16
hours on your feet walking around hot
just nothing like trying to find a taxi
cab at four in the morning from the ill
morning or parking because if if you
rent a car and you got a hotel room it's
literally what hell is made of
south by southwest
is the worst [ __ ] ever
i i so low man
but i also know that like
i walked four and a half miles at 3 30
in the morning because i couldn't get a
[ __ ] cab yo
and like you said
sometimes your hotel room is off in the
cut far so when you're done doing eleven
random i mean cheese shows oh you all
you hearing
all the rapping you're going there it's
it's it gets it gets crazy i remember
when um sprite do you remember that
sprite had first uh popped off and was
called it was like weezy yeah it was
with it you know how many people thought
it was a new artist because it was the
back of lil wayne's head
but it was like crazy you saying do
weezy everywhere who is this new rapper
that they took off myself
bro south by is uh yeah it's good times
i hope it it it somehow regains its i
was talking to the homie brian hobbs
who works there and i was i was like i
hope that all right
brian's good guy
and i hope that the two-year break might
have might readjust it because it got to
the point where it was super organic and
it truly felt special and then like this
there was a doritos stage with lady gaga
yeah once it got to that point it was
i'm like what the [ __ ] is lady gaga
doing here this is not for her
it was the the labels got a hold of it
that pepsi got a whole thing [ __ ] you
and then now everyone's got a stick oh
my god every bro i posted on on on ig
the other day that i was going to be at
south by yeah i got at least 30 dms
yo come to my stage come to my stage or
yo how much did you get on your stage
i'm like dude
first of all
our up and coming artists if you're
watching this and someone tries to
charge you to get on their shitty south
by southwest stage
tell them to go [ __ ] themselves
lord jesus because it's not gonna do
anything for your [ __ ] rap career nah
you might as well take all that money
and buy youtube ads for the last music
video
but back in the day because you're gonna
spend that money and you're gonna
perform for 60 stinky ass people who
don't even want to be there they're just
there because it's the only thing they
could get into at the time you really
don't want to go
i don't wait what the [ __ ] that's we got
rookie cards over there what are we
doing
oh this is [ __ ] you got basketball cards
yeah oh what do we got we got some drama
rants over there
he we won't he looking forward that's it
do you collect basketball cards nah
that's that that that would be a very
expensive habit for me also if you would
have started like at the beginning of
the pandemic a pretty fruitful habit
yeah but i mean and i i'm like i'm a
gamer to some degree what do you play
man i play nba 2k mlb the show been my
[ __ ] for the past year and some change
i've been playing the [ __ ] out that game
cause it's i'm a baseball player at
heart and then i'm playing this [ __ ]
called elden ring right now my son just
told me today
is ridiculous he said it was uh what was
the name
elder scrolls was that the name of that
one he says it's like the new version of
that bro i've never played a game like
this before but that [ __ ] is so
inner like it's like some medieval time
dragon ass [ __ ] i don't know how the
[ __ ] they came up with the idea to
create something like this bro it's just
so weird
it's fire as [ __ ] bro it's taking up too
much of my time right now you're gonna
get on twitch
i i tried to but it's something i'm so
competitive so they're gonna probably be
like hey bro you don't have to win on
twitch you just you also could just talk
[ __ ] i mean listen see i'm i'm like
[ __ ] if i [ __ ] up i'm like pissed and
then i'm trying to be like nice and [ __ ]
you don't want to get yours
you don't want to get canceled like that
dude on the heat bro you remember the
guy on the heat who got smoked and he's
hits he said some crazy jewish [ __ ] is
he
myers
and they they released him and he's
still not in the league
and he's a seven f he's like a six foot
ten white guy who can hit threes he's
done oh yeah off of twitch and in the
moments you get pissed off and just say
did you see snoop rage quit
on man
yeah i've seen him but it's it's real
though and i mean and i also don't want
if some stuff i do with my free time is
just for me it's for you with that being
said t-payne's making an extremely
expensive amount of money he's crushing
but he's crushing it and it works over t
and t payne is very he don't give a [ __ ]
he's kind of made for twitch yeah it
works it works the homie podcast and all
that it it it works well have you gone
on his podcast not yet but i'm supposed
to so good support i need to hit the
homie yeah payne's a good guy yeah he's
at home yo stop at the interview got to
tell you about our good folks at odd
socks man listen go to odd socks
official dot com use the promo code 20
off save 20 off some of the craziest
socks you know they got the ninja turtle
joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
y'all be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
one thing i like about t payne is like
he's kind of like unapologetically
himself don't give a [ __ ] whether or not
it's like
he goes against whatever
popular like popular belief like he just
is like yo this is how i feel yeah
another cool thing about payne is like
you're like no matter what you're just
one record away again always i mean but
this is the thing he sees wrote so many
he records just i mean he's one of the
greatest
hit makers ever and so it's kind of like
you know to see him also just see a lot
of these artists transform out of just
making music and actually finding the
place where they
the the personality starts to shine i
think is a kind of a great step moving
forward for a lot of artists because
this is the thing rap we've yet to see a
rapper retire
except joe budden apparently yeah i mean
but but just to be like i i'm done yeah
because jay-z retired and then came out
with kingdom come and we were like
lifetime achievement award kind of game
right so we what is the transition for
artists i think all of us do have a
voice beyond it just being on a beat
and so i think looking at people like um
joe budding or looking at a t-pain even
killer mike's done a good job smoke this
is doing right now
it's like
okay you know get to the point we really
talking versus it being the instrumental
behind yeah like action bronson i think
was early too with that doing his [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's delicious
shout out to him too that guy
yeah
he looks like one of those guys do you
remember back in the day on the
religious channel they used to tear
phone books he looks like one of those
i remember those guys used to like tell
phone books and jesus came
i feel like he could tear a phone book i
definitely peeped his trajectory man i'm
proud of the homie and i think that's
another thing too that if nothing else
if music can't give us the opportunity
to completely change our lifestyles in
the healthiest way possible and a lot of
us between the partying and the [ __ ]
it off on tour years and years
at some point it catches up to you right
you've been in the game long enough to
have peers that have come and gone as
far as musically yeah uh you know and
unfortunately in actually being here
yeah in physical form
um
you know i think of just like some of
the artists that
came along the way with you that
aren't rapping anymore we don't hear
from in your opinion who's like
maybe the biggest what if of all time or
maybe the biggest artist where you were
like you know maybe you don't think they
got the chance
or or just things didn't necessarily
work out
how you would hoped for them
i'll give you mine first to break the
ice i'm gonna say pill
peel definitely pillow man peel yeah
pink city
um damn dutch what's the homie name from
mississippi bro
uh the homie that went on tour with us i
can't think of his name my brain's just
uh
tito lopez tito lopez was so fire
jamming bro
and he was like wasn't he on aftermath
yeah i think he was riding over there
and dude tito lopez did a freestyle for
my mixtape and at a uh
we lived in the same neighborhood in las
vegas for a little bit yeah and the
homie i don't think got a fair shake you
know tito lopez was so cold
xv
was oh wow
zero heroes
he went to warner brothers and i
man i don't know what they did it just
it's just one of them things man when
you
they
the excitement of science charles
hamilton
ah yeah
[ __ ] man yeah those green lantern
mixtapes
the green lantern mix tapes are crazy
it's just going to the labels sometimes
that's that's by weighing them sometimes
that's when the hard work really starts
that's when it starts not to when you're
independent because you it's like uh
when you move in to promote your music
and it's in your independent do it you
don't even think about it as much as
like oh just hit my cd it's just
excitement listen boom once you got the
ear
and the support that's when the pressure
kind of takes a different kind of hole
because every song you're trying to make
sure every song is just the [ __ ]
and it can take you totally out of your
creative space i think too like not
everyone
maybe understands how hard it is
to be a an artist
that your entire livelihood is based on
a subjective thing
and sometimes this objective that's the
subjective thing is not
it's not the gatekeeper of whether or
not it's good enough isn't the people as
much as it's whoever the [ __ ] is in the
boardroom
you know what i'm saying like i think
it's like a side though they actually
give you the support necessary we're
talking about literal art you know what
i'm saying like and
yeah i think i like someone like xv and
like oh my god this dude dropped classic
music and for whatever reason just
warner brothers just
man i can't like so in even in the
process of putting the music out and
going through that when you're done with
the album and what that means and
it's like you become the album in a
certain like you live it you know with
even with the tapes it's like you could
do that and breathe and then you're
working on something else when you do
your album you've got to that's what you
put out you got to own that forever some
change and tour everything is surrounded
around this one creative project and it
could take you a year and a half to make
it and it takes people 45 minutes to
listen to have an opinion and be like oh
i don't like it that's right
you like i just spent that [ __ ] just
happened with roddy rich roddy rich took
two years to put his out mountain people
just hated it and it's like he deleted
his instagram he's like what do you
create it's like what do you do with
like how do you how it's hard to move
forward because dude you got to live it
you in it though you're just out now
yeah and you just gotta wait till you
can't unrelease you can't you can't
unrelease it bro yeah was there a point
in time where you felt like you were
getting maybe
i wouldn't say depressed but maybe you
were just
down and out when it came to just
everything man that that that that could
that could be your that's yesterday you
know it's one of those things where i've
been doing this also for so long and
that sometimes i have to be like where
else in my life
like what's next for me you know i've
spent
you know my teenage years up until this
point with the one focal idea of i do
music and i love this art form but i
think i started to give it a certain
kind of power over my life and how i
feel about myself and anxiety and if i'm
not doing music then i'm not doing
anything and that's not true
that's true and so the two years to take
off not drop a album drop an album and
you go right back into that
what y'all think about it and then that
can just dial you all the way down into
a depression anxiety because if people
don't like it you gotta live with that
i mean look i think at the end of the
day man
you gotta know
if you're going to put something out
that you're you're just okay with
whatever comes with it that takes time
most artists we never find that comfort
because if for you to come out two years
and drop a project like this one
it's a risk but it's also like you got
to know this is some good this is good
like and that's but see you just say it
but it's subjective i know it's jamming
i [ __ ] know i'm like man i put a lot
i know this because i wouldn't want to
listen to it if it wasn't but that don't
take away from what somebody else might
want or hear want from me right right
and then it mostly where's the mall
where's my sub part 11 yeah right but
most of it is a part of whatever
point in their life they they
because that's the kind of music i've
really got to start making it wasn't
about oh this is the kind of kick drum
and schneider everybody using i'm using
that this is kind of high head oh this
the flow this the tempo i'm gonna do
that i don't do that with my music i'm
like oh i'm gonna make a song about
a breakup in in a kind of way where i'm
trying to forgive myself for doing wrong
because that's what i go through that's
why i've experienced that in life and it
needs to be heard you know and despite
what people may feel about it in the
moment if they go through a breakup at
least they know they can relate to me
yeah i think they're ready i think
everyone's got i mean for the most part
everyone's gone through something like
that and the relatability of that is
you know a lot more um
like timeless yeah that'll be there
forever yeah so did this
album was there a specific relationship
that happened that all of them or was it
just an accumulation of yeah having to
go back and look at whatever patterns i
have and the excitement of when you
first get with somebody then when you
get comfortable and then you start
questioning
how far this relationship is going to go
and then that i feel like you know
there's always that process in a
relationship you pretty much just kind
of nailed it
and the thing is is once you get to that
weird space
of like
past the comfortable yeah
if you can make it through that then you
got something then you got something
yeah and you and that and the album is
literally that and and but it's
being comfortable with the experience
whether it was good or bad learning from
the experience that's why the record all
the time i spent the idea of i spent so
much time gaining material things and
wanting this and it didn't really change
the narrative of what love is and how it
could blossom or i could it could die
but growing from that like well at least
i loved it all
um and tying it all back in with more
than roses is the end which is despite
what we deal with in life we interact
with each other we build and communicate
and we need to like we need community so
there it is um
the rest of your i mean obviously
tourists happen in april april 22nd man
i'm getting my you're excited you're
together for that now yeah i'm excited
and terrified you'll be in front of all
those people no one's gonna be wearing
masks
omicron's gonna be lurking boy
hey well you know what's crazy is i
haven't heard anybody in the last couple
of weeks get covered hey but look you
know i'm just a couple of weeks ago
everyone everyone and their mom had this
[ __ ] but i feel like the last week and a
half or two i haven't heard i haven't
seen a lot of people saying i'm popping
man i caught that [ __ ] thanksgiving of
last year bro that ain't nothing nobody
want omicron or delta or whatever kind
just
i caught that [ __ ] it didn't it wasn't
it wasn't well i had a light whatever
did you vax that thing up huh did you
vax that thing up as juvenile said huh
you see did you see the juvenile video
huh yeah i saw this video i noticed you
i don't know i wouldn't hear rogers dude
what didn't roger
[Music]
yo that was not [ __ ] with aaron
rodgers no i mean but come on man he i
mean i'm not going to fight he punk fake
yeah he puffed the [ __ ] out of here he
said yeah i'm immunized
it was like he just made that [ __ ] up on
the spot though
on the [ __ ] spot but he actually he
got over it quick they still talking
about my homie kyrie irving like i mean
kyrie to me was like
i'm not doing it he just was like hey
but that shows me that when you talented
and you do you great at what you do
that they'll they'll adjust the
situation of course they will and and
and the asinine part of it is that if
you play for a different team and you go
to the net stadium you can play but if
you play for the net and you're not
vaccinating yeah but if you if you
aren't vaccinated and you play for the
nets you can't play
i'm like but he's still then basically
still playing around everybody anyway
though he's practicing with that i don't
understand any of it the kyrie thing he
just put 50 up against the hornets last
night got crazy the ball
the only thing they're going to hit a
snag is if they um
they end up running into the raptors in
that playing game because
and the raptors pl if they play in
toronto kyrie can't play there oh [ __ ]
canada
so that because right now they're the
eight seed like the nestor the worst the
second
they've lost yeah because kevin was hurt
yeah so they've been terrible
so
i'm you're a basketball fan yeah i i
haven't got the opportunity to dive into
it this much
this year i know that uh you don't have
basketball you don't have stacks of
basketball cards no i don't but she also
just on deck i'm a fan of players so
lebron is definitely you know what i'm
saying is lebron your favorite player
yes right now i would say that
definitely yeah he's my favorite player
ever
and to see the work he put here every
night just he put up 56 the other night
bro
year 19. that's what i'm saying bro and
then to still be in a situation where
you hey what team was that against
no what team was it against
the oh the warriors it was against the
warriors that's crazy
but did they
see his hat
did the lakers win though because yeah
no they won
oh they won okay yeah they all they won
i'll tell you who hasn't been winning a
lot lately the [ __ ] warriors they
fell out of that three seed
oh yeah the the grizzlies are the two
seed right now you think it's because
you think it's good you know who's the
one seed the phoenix [ __ ] suns yeah
they're going crazy charles barkley's
behind you he's proud oh okay you know
what i'm saying
yes shout out to you how do you feel
about devon booker he's balling ain't
from mississippi so is he from
mississippi mississippi yeah
he's from ray schrammer from
devon booker yeah i thought he was from
michigan he played high school in
michigan oh yeah
mississippi though
you mean to tell me the same city in
mississippi produced ray schremert and
devin booker that thing is amazing this
might be the greatest city in the
country
because that's
arguably the best rap duo since mob deep
and devin boogers i mean he's he's
crushing it yeah he's he's just an angel
sent from god to say phoenix sons
basketball so i forgot that's no spot
it sure the [ __ ] is it's crazy you ain't
even there no more though yeah i mean
i'm there once i'm there once a month
i'm there once a month you be turning up
in that [ __ ] then yeah i'm still
waiting on mississippi to get a
basketball team i don't know if that's
ever gonna happen that [ __ ] should
happen though bro i don't know
you know there's this stick you know
growing up
you know what it is growing up as a
little kid i rented burning mississippi
from the library
and ever since then i just thought
mississippi's full of the clan no i mean
well that's that that that's everywhere
that was with matthew mcconaughey and
samuel jackson do you remember that
movie tom the keel
or no it's time to kill wasn't that in
mississippi i don't know it was in
mississippi right stop look it's all
good that i got mississippi masala that
was a good movie you know what the [ __ ]
that is denzel washington
um see i have to find there was a
burning mississippi but i'm worried
about that and then there was time i
think at times see and that's the
problem bro it's it's not what people
think about that's all i think i'm like
yeah you need to you need to when i live
so when i lived in tampa oh my god
because i lived in tampa i mean i saw
you a bunch when i was in tampa
i remember we drove uh me and my boys
they helped me move to tampa and you
know all my friends are people of color
so we're driving through uh
and we stop in houston and they tell us
they're like hey
there's this area of east texas
you do not stop for anything hmm it is i
think we know it rains
they're like yo they are openly racist
there's billboards it is like the clan
like head
vitor it starts with a v
yeah
see it's everywhere and i googled this
[ __ ] and it's literally
there
they're telling you
keep driving
on billboards like it's it's [ __ ]
crazy i wonder who won vitor in the 2020
election who do you think who do you
think took it do you think buying a
ticket
i'm just curious who do you think took
east texas lord jesus who won that
district
joe byron
yeah i know uh nah man but but
mississippi is not what people think at
least i mean and if people don't like
you you know it and it ain't no
ain't no pump they don't palm fake with
that it was having to get used to people
not liking me but pretending they did
when i went everywhere else is deion
sanders the best thing to happen to
mississippi since big crit
when it comes to jackson state football
team i would say so he is crushing it
he's a couple toes short right now he
had a couple toes amputated yesterday
for real yeah you know he's been riding
around on that scooter because of his
legs
so i guess there was a complication with
the surgery so they had to amputate two
of his toes god damn the fact he's able
to recruit the players he's recruiting
to jackson he's gonna change hbc it's
crazy and it should be i mean but
these not only are they powerhouses but
it's just good to see these schools
start getting some kind of recognition i
just hope he has like another five years
there because
anybody's gonna come along one of these
major schools florida state uh
oren if the right nfl job imagine if the
cowboys fire mike mccarthy they're going
to offer dion sanders a coaching
position that would be amazing so it's
just whether or not he's like now i need
to build a legacy here first because if
he leaves it there's you know
he brought he's bringing a lot to that
situation it is i mean but i would
wonder if he would even want to do that
though that's what i'm saying i mean
he's prime time he's rich already yeah
so i think
he's got rap albums yeah it'd be
i'll be surprised i mean it seems like a
just a whole nother rejuvenation for him
being around the college kids and
working on the campus i can't imagine
the pressure of being an nfl coach
versus when you had the college and the
band it's just a whole nother are you a
football guy
ah
kind of more of a baseball game more of
a baseball guy would you say baseball is
your favorite sport that's what sport i
played
so you like because baseball is a
terrible thing to watch
but do you watch baseball how about that
uh
uh every so often i feel like it's a
good thing to just have on in the
background
like you throw it on and then it's like
oh it's eighth inning
lately i've been watching just the mlb
network bro and then you watch the movie
now because they they play the old games
do they pay you no i'm just watching i
mean like they have games with ernie
banks and noah parker and [ __ ] like that
yeah you can watch like joe morgan and
this [ __ ] looks crazy i remember saying
something
hey
yeah like yeah oh that documentary was
crazy i hope they br that [ __ ] was fire
yeah that was crazy i hope they bring
steroids back
bro they hitting home runs again nah
they need roids bruh they hitting are
they hitting them these pictures is
there's too many strikeouts happening in
baseball i mean but they but they they
like bro they hit the home run and
there's a what's it a lockout what is it
called well yeah they ain't started yet
but i still got the video game have you
ever gone to spring training no i wanted
to try out though for baseball i want to
try out for the braves i want to be on
some rudy [ __ ] [ __ ] you know will
ferrell did it oh for real he got onto a
spring training team they let him play
for like a week
they fooled me because i didn't know
that was fake
i was like [ __ ] will ferrell
[Music]
he's [ __ ] 48 out there i literally
want to try out and then play one game
and then retire on some rudy [ __ ] you
just want to be able to say i got my own
jersey that but it's kind of like what
cole did you want to walk
and play though yeah you wanna you wanna
go but this is the thing bro they throw
us they they like we actually went to
one of the games bro and they throwing
that ball so [ __ ] hard bro what's
what's your uh position when you play i
was a catcher shortstop then i was in
left field eyes got so you just played
everything yeah i was a pitcher too
though i threw three quarters yeah
what was the fastest ball you ever threw
uh 92. that's pretty [ __ ] fast yeah
so but i stopped in
once i once i made
my first 500 off beats i was like oh no
[ __ ] this baseball
because i for me i wasn't going to go
straight pro it's going to be the
college it's going to be single a double
a it's a struggle i mean i could have
been doing i could have been in single a
or double a right now
still still still trying to get called
up
no you see that [ __ ] all the time you'll
be watching a baseball game and they'll
be like
11-year
aaa veteran first time in the major
leagues i got a isis knees and all this
[ __ ] yeah and then you've been and then
you know that's a different kind of
grind chick playing and modeling yeah
yeah
different check it's like being the w
nba player
man oh my god no bro it's not as far as
pay
but they just first i think they just
they're fun to try to fix that now
because i sure hope so yeah they deserve
way more because the wma players getting
[ __ ] and they go hard though i feel so
bad for them because it's like i just
saw something that somebody's signing
bonus was
more than uh
the entire wnba's salaries combined
every employee that don't make no sense
it's wild because you have to play
overseas
brittany
she was on her way to russia
because that's where she has to go to
play to make money
she they were paying her a million
dollars to play in the russian league so
in the off season she gets paid a
million bucks for the for the season
in russia
yeah
it's definitely unfair though bro i'm
like how does diana taurasi how do i
make more money than diana taurasi how
is that even possible it's diana brock
she's the greatest female basketball
player of all time she's the female
lebron they're going to change this
though they better yeah this has been uh
yeah because again the women's soccer
team didn't cashed out now they finally
got them right are you a big enough
lebron fan
to purchase his shoes yes because i have
so many pairs of lebron yes i
i got that was the the miami ones the
devices yeah that [ __ ] was hard yeah
they've been so i know how old i am now
because all the lebrons i used to buy
are now on their 10-year anniversary so
they're re-releasing them
so i'm like
i'm living through
the anniversary where they're retro in
the bronze my g it's some [ __ ] that
people say is vintage that i'm like bro
that uh that's not vintage oh yeah this
is all done watching tv i got this
vintage 10 deep shirt 10d yes
like vintage [ __ ] what you mean
rockstar all that [ __ ] yeah i forgot
crooks and castles and [ __ ] books and
cat they're back now lrg's back word
yeah i used to be large eat out shout
out to my guy kev lrg sponsors our
freestyle series
and drake just randomly three nights ago
he went on a lrg posting spree and he
posted like seven lrg ads from like the
early 2000s on his story for no reason
just what are they gonna be up now [ __ ]
so i had to call my boy i was like
haters drake on their argument he's like
i don't think so but we're [ __ ] happy
those brands definitely show love in the
beginning of the south lrg had all the
[ __ ] ill [ __ ] doing their
ads diamond was right there with them
diamonds
just yeah guys
out there wearing you know remember the
[ __ ] skeleton hoodie
did you go all the way up the lrg joint
kanye wore that [ __ ] hmm
the good times man they still are the
[ __ ] lrg still is the [ __ ]
if you love lrg go to lrg
l
hyphen r hyphen g.com promo code bootleg
30 percent off your your checkout go to
bigquery.com forward slash tour and buy
some tickets yes because we're going to
be in the city near you how many seconds
how many dates does
34 34 is there a city you just won't
[ __ ] go to anymore you're like [ __ ]
yeah i can't say just tell us
that i mean is it
cleveland no it ain't clean
up in cleveland we go to cleveland i'm
just curious because i know i mean
sometimes it's not even the city it's it
might be the venue it might be the
speakers the sound system or something
like that i'm not [ __ ] with
you know but the people there's always
love it's just i want them to experience
the music
okay you've been all over the country
what's your least favorite city you've
been to not even touring wise just
experience
i can't say that i'll give you mine
first oh my god bro
it's either between mobile alabama um
that was god-awful
or twin falls
idaho um
terrible place
[Music]
i lived in boise for 12 months mobile
was turned the people was turned
you're looking at it as your live shows
i just mean your visiting experience oh
i don't know man no it's always the show
are you just visiting and i don't know
you're passing through and you're like
god this place [ __ ] sucks oh like i
don't want to be i don't i don't know
who lives here
i can't say life blythe california
terrible place
i can't i don't i don't i don't find
myself in those kinds of like you know
if you're taking a vacation you regret
it
wow
yes i've done that before where was it
at and it might not even it has nothing
to do with this place it might just be
the experience the hotel [ __ ] sucked
me and my wife just went to the dr
pictures looked amazing the hotel was it
was nice it was inclusive but the food
was it was it was like jail food
i can't really i don't know man i think
i i went to new york thinking i was
going to just relax go see some art
stuff like in new york and then just was
one of the moments it was one of the
experiences where like the hotel's small
i didn't really get what i wanted out of
those small hotels
out of the experience the hotels in new
york people don't know this but if you
go i mean if the people who know know
but you go to new york
the hotel's the size of a closet it's it
was it was tiny and then it was like i
don't know it was it was it was like
supposed to be one of these um kind of
like upscale when you walk in of course
it's like like the the lobby's super
nice yeah it just when you get to the
closet it wasn't ruined it wasn't and
then i was there for like two days and
[ __ ] and i went out i'm good when i go
to new york
i enjoy
however long i'm there but the entire
time i'm there i'm like how do these
[ __ ] people do this i just feel like
i gotta work a lot when i get up there
is like you you gotta go it's just
moving so
hectic
every part of your day
park in your car
the the the cab the cab thing and just
every little thing is like you're
dealing with people you're
it's just like it took me a long time to
to get comfortable going there and not
feeling like um like i was in a hurry or
something like that yeah i i respect new
yorkers so much because i don't know how
they i could i just couldn't i had to
start with hanging out with smoke dizza
and like be going around moving around
seeing stuff uh i ended up going to
this amazing museum with my homie stevo
and then it was like oh okay there is
aspects of this why i don't feel like oh
i need to be i gotta do it if i'm doing
mad interviews i'm running back and
forth um and so it's it's just finding
like small places what about
country-wise what's your favorite
non-united states country oh man i love
australia australia i love it i have
heard that if you are of a certain tone
that might be yours
that the women in australia
are up for grabs it's awesome man perth
is like perth reminded me every
chick-fil-a iggy azalea
ah
no it's it's a it's a plethora going on
it's it's very it's it's amazing okay
well you were saying perth reminded you
of my hometown but it was so the weather
and then it's like this the house it was
crazy i was like man i could [ __ ]
live here aside from the big ass spiders
and the birds that'll kill you
wait the birds will kill you there's
some birds over there to get at that ass
so but other than that bro we best food
i ate
like over there bro what is the food is
it like a blooming onion no
it's food it's like you know they had
this bomb and stir-fry rice with this
hotel and i was like but it should taste
so fresh
is it kind of like the us over there
i've heard it's like australia just like
the u.s but just
fire it's people sleep on it was it
melbourne and it was like it felt like
new york but it was you had shows over
there yeah we had four had a whole tour
over there that's big super low and it
was crazy i'm [ __ ] doing country [ __ ]
in australia in australia and they and
it's crazy because we on stage and i'm
telling well before the shows are like
[ __ ] i don't even ain't you know we
don't know what to expect don't know
what the [ __ ] to expect as soon as we 86
they going [ __ ] crazy you know and
i'm like wow more country women came a
long [ __ ] way
hey man the tour uh get your tickets the
album
uh the girl talk project what's the name
of the actual project full court press
full court press that's yourself
uh currency's on it but he's not a part
of the actual
collapse i mean but just by default my
default uh smoke deserve whiz
shout out to whiz yes
how's your relationship with wiz these
days because he's like one of the few
people in the music industry
who in my opinion i've been really close
with him and will for over a decade now
and i kind of feel like he's always kind
of been the same guy the homie ain't
forgot
where you come from it's like all the
success he's still he's still him still
uh we on the tour bus talking [ __ ]
having fun um and it's it's again it's
like that family union kind of vibe and
feel and we we in the studio bro it's
not even it ain't no ego driven [ __ ]
it's like bro we talking about how
things was like this how about southwest
what it was like being on tour and
um even the the the college show with
the the they got locked to cnn all this
[ __ ] was like bro we haven't been
through some [ __ ]
and we still making jam and ass music
and getting laughs about it so
um and it's just good to to be around
that like though even the amount of
success we gain it don't change how we
are as people
side note how many actual songs did you
and yellow com ever complete for country
cousins did it even happen or was it
just talked about happening we did that
one record the hip-hop record and then
i think then we did the the um
full of [ __ ] record and i think that was
really it bro
that's crazy now he's making rock music
yeah shout out to wolf shout out to uh
big crit uh
the album is out two albums around uh
yeah well yeah well april 8th is when
the full court press come out and i'm
just i mean hopefully we get another one
before the end of the year i mean i
might do that for you who the [ __ ] knows
man who are you a fan of right now that
just gives you like the energy that that
you're like man this [ __ ] is still good
like i'm loving what these what this guy
is doing team akin ali
dear silas and these two boys out of
mississippi and they crushed it they
definitely on to some [ __ ] man of g
yamazawa
you know out of north carolina
um it's another there's a couple few
others i can't think oh childish major
trout is majors dope i saw him open for
isaiah rashad i think yeah he killed him
yeah and so it's it's
in in just the growth and seeing why
everybody's kind of at musically right
now it's just like you know everybody's
willing to experiment on stage too yeah
not for sure so i mean but these these
young cats don't i'm looking forward to
seeing how you perform this new album me
too me too bro i'm definitely i'm
definitely gonna have to get my vocal
chords together because i'm gonna tell
you something ain't no way in here i'm
gonna be able to do country [ __ ] and
then start singing so cool you'll be
sweating i'm gonna be not damn my voice
gonna be tore up if
[Music]
experience as much as possible though
bro there it is big crit
appreciate your time go support go buy
some i'm sure there's merch yes we got
all that is there going to be an nft
oh yeah yeah bro yeah yeah yeah just
don't don't do don't do what the aaron
fox from the [ __ ] kings did because
they're investigating his ass he's worth
180 million dollars and folks i don't
know what he did but no i'm not we we're
legit we don't i mean the album name you
would feel like there should be an nft
definitely
it's coming yeah we doing it bro there
it is man big crit appreciate you
brother always thank you fire sir